Was ist jetzt?
- Ein Überfallalarm bei einer Bank.
Mitten im Briefing, das kommt vor.
Rasch ausrüsten und dann los.
Ein Alltag wie im Krimi: Verbrecher
jagen, das Böse eliminieren.
Das die landläufige Vorstellung
eines Polizistenalltags.
Wie viel hat das wirklich
mit der Realität zu tun?
Wir wollen es herausfinden.
Yves Chappuis von der Polizei
Basel-Landschaft nimmt uns mit.
Er zeigt uns
ungefiltert seinen Alltag.
* Sirene *
* Spannende Klänge *
Hallo, Dani. Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
Vor der Bank ist es ruhig.
Irgendjemand
hat den Alarm ausgelöst.
1102 hat verstanden.
Ein Fehlalarm.
Aber die genaue Ursache
habe ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Auf jeden Fall
war es kein echter Alarm.
Also, es ging ein echter Alarm raus,
aber es ist nichts passiert.
Aber das ist
eigentlich der Klassiker:
Man muss mit allem rechnen.
- Ja.
Man geht nicht einfach blindlings
von einem Fehlalarm aus.
Jeder Alarm
ist als echt einzustufen,
ansonsten fällt man
irgendwann auf die Nase.
Bei einem Einsatz weiss Yves Chappuis
nicht, was er vor Ort genau antrifft.
Er muss immer
mit dem Schlimmsten rechnen -
auch wenn das nur selten eintrifft.
Auch jetzt: Eine Frau schlägt Alarm.
Seit zwei Tagen kein Lebenszeichen
von ihrem Nachbarn.
Normalerweise
sind sie täglich in Kontakt.
Sein Briefkasten ungeleert,
die Storen unten.
Ein Mehrfamilienhaus.
Hier wartet jemand.
(Navigationsgerät) Ankunft.
Guten Tag.
- (Frau) Guten Tag.
- Frau Bender.
Kunzelmann, guten Tag.
- Guten Tag, Chappuis.
Guten Tag, Chappuis.
- Die Frau hat Sie angerufen.
Wegen des alten Herrn hier.
- Ich habe einen Schlüssel.
Aber nicht ganz voll.
- Aha.
* Lautes Klopfen *
* Schwacher Ruf *
Ich habe etwas gehört.
Ja. Polizei.
Oh!
- Ich habe etwas gehört.
Josie ist da.
* Unverständliches Murmeln *
Oh, seine Stimme klingt,
als könne er sich nicht bewegen.
Ja, seine Stimme klingt,
Sonst spricht er deutlich.
Der Schlüssel steckt von innen.
- Nein!
Kannst du nicht zur Tür gehen?
Wo bist du?
Wo ist die Terrasse?
- Hinten.
Draussen.
- Ich versuche kurz ...
Ich bleibe mal hier.
- Ja.
Chappuis bekommt
Informationen von seinem Kollegen.
Er liegt eingeschlossen
und blutverschmiert am Boden.
Hier komme ich nicht rein.
Der Schlüssel steckt von innen.
Wie kommen wir rein?
Durch den Haupteingang
mit dem Schlüsseldienst
oder kann man bei dir öffnen?
Dass wir zu Einbrechern werden,
ist eine ungewohnte Situation.
Rollentausch?
- (Lachend) Ja.
Aber in diesem Fall ist es nötig.
Haben wir beide Platz?
- Ja, das geht schon.
Ah, bäng!
- Jetzt ist es offen.
Hallo.
- Hallo. Polizei.
* Der ältere Mann
spricht unverständlich. *
Der Krankenwagen ist unterwegs.
- (Älterer Mann) Ja.
Was ist passiert?
- Ich weiss es gar nicht.
Wahrscheinlich sind Sie gestürzt.
Es wurde höchste Zeit,
dass Hilfe kam.
(Frau Bender) Erkennst du mich?
Hallo miteinander.
- (Sanitäter) Guten Morgen.
(Sanitäter) Hat sich hier
jemand den Kopf gestossen?
Warte, bis er ganz unten ist.
Nimmst du die Beine?
- Ich habe ihn, ja.
(Sanitäter) Gut, habt ihr ihn?
Ein bisschen runter.
Gut.
- Wir lassen ihn gleich hier drauf.
Danke schön.
Gut, okay.
- Trotzdem einen schönen Tag.
Gleichfalls, danke.
- Vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank.
- Bitte, gerne.
Nicht zuletzt wegen solcher Momente
ist Yves Chappuis Polizist geworden.
Meine Grundhaltung ist,
dass ich den Menschen helfen
und sie in ihrem täglichen Leben
unterstützen möchte.
Wenn ich mit Menschen zu tun habe,
bemühe ich mich, ihre Geschichte
ernst zu nehmen und ihnen zuzuhören.
Zudem tue ich mein Bestes, um dafür
zu sorgen, dass der Fall gut läuft.
55-mal pro Tag
rückt die Polizei Basel-Landschaft
durchschnittlich aus.
Schnell umschalten ist gefragt -
von einem Fall zum nächsten.
(Mann über Funk)
Ihr zehnjähriger Sohn
wurde auf dem Schulweg anscheinend
von einem Mann angesprungen.
Der Notruf einer Mutter.
Ihr Sohn wurde auf dem Schulweg
von einem Mann attackiert.
Und Sie sind?
- Der Vater.
Der Vater.
Und Sie sind die Mutter. Okay.
Damit wir wissen, wer, wie und wo.
Der Mann versteckte sich
hinter einem Gebüsch,
kam hervor und rannte auf dich zu?
- Ja.
Er hatte schwarze und ...
... schwarze und braune Haare.
Also, schwarz oder braun?
Braun.
- Einfach dunkle Haare? - Ja.
Und er hatte braune Haut.
Und, äh, danach versteckte er sich
irgendwo, neben der Garage oder so.
Und danach ...
Nicht "oder so". Du musst es so
erzählen wie mir. Einfach langsam.
Versteckte er sich denn dort hinten
oder stand er plötzlich da?
Ja, er rannte hinter mir her.
Und dann boxte er dich ohne etwas zu
sagen mit beiden Fäusten. Wo genau?
Hier.
- Gegen die Rippen.
Ja.
- Sieht man etwas?
Hast du nachgesehen?
- Also, nein.
Bist du irgendwie ...
- Ein bisschen.
Chappuis schaut sich den Tatort an.
Der Junge soll ihm zeigen, wo
und wie sich der Mann versteckt hat.
Von hier kam er? Okay.
Ich sah ihn aus dem Gebüsch kommen.
Ein Fall mit vielen Fragezeichen.
Das ist doch ein Stück. Also,
irgendwie ist das doch nicht ...
Ja, das muss man halt ...
- Es passt irgendwie nicht in ...
Das sprach ich vorhin ja an.
Aber wenn es so dargestellt wird,
dann ...
Chappuis' Aufgabe:
Die Fälle aufnehmen und dann
der Staatsanwaltschaft übergeben.
2017 wurden in Basel-Landschaft
37 % aller Delikte aufgeklärt.
Zeit für eine Verschnaufpause.
Yves Chappuis
und sein Kollege Nicolas Behrend
grillieren
im Garten des Polizeipostens.
Ein Moment der Ruhe
im hektischen Polizistenalltag.
Dann gibt's morgen Nacht noch etwas.
Wir machen morgen Fajitas.
Wenn ich heute wüsste,
wie es draussen läuft,
würde ich es mir zweimal überlegen,
nochmals diesen Beruf zu wählen.
Warum?
- Weil es schon ziemlich ...
... belastend ist. V.a.
die unregelmässigen Arbeitszeiten.
Mal Früh-,
mal Nacht- und mal Mittelschicht.
Und dann noch am Schalter.
Das belastet einen schon.
Belastet es auch das Privatleben?
Das auch, ja.
Man kann sich
nicht immer genügend ausruhen
und dementsprechend verändert sich
z.T. auch die Laune ein bisschen.
Und das kriegt dann die Familie ab?
- Ja, die Familie und Freunde.
Aber ansonsten ist der Beruf
spannend und gefällt mir. Daher ...
Ich bin froh, dass ich ihn wählte.
Eine überraschende Aussage -
nicht der psychologische Teil zehrt.
Es sind die Arbeitszeiten, die den
zweifachen Familienvater belasten.
Heute hat Chappuis Doppelschicht.
D.h., von 6 Uhr morgens
bis mittags um 12.30 Uhr
und dann die ganze Nacht
bis am nächsten Morgen um 6 Uhr.
Noch ist es ruhig.
Noch kein Alarm.
Ich erinnere mich noch an die erste
Zeit nach der Aspirantenschule.
Damals schnallte ich den Gürtel um,
war aufgeregt und wartete
auf den ersten Funkspruch.
Aber heute, nach 15 Jahren,
ist das eigentlich Alltag.
Ich ziehe mich an
und dann kommt etwas.
Oder es kommt nichts.
An diesem Tag kommt nicht viel.
Ausser einer verlorenen Radkappe.
Gut.
In der Nacht aber
geht es Schlag auf Schlag.
(Über Funk)
Ja, verstanden, wir fahren.
Ein Einbruch in einem Hotel.
* Spannende Klänge *
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
Ja, verstanden. Wir sind
in Therwil unterwegs. Mariastein.
Da vorn, wo die Schirme sind.
- Genau.
Wohin gehst du?
- Links.
Links, okay. Ich gehe rechts.
Ja, hier ist alles okay.
Hier ist auch abgeschlossen. Gut.
Wenn man als erste Patrouille vor
Ort ist, umstellt man das Objekt.
Man sichert die Eckpunkte.
Dann geht man alleine
in die Dunkelheit und weiss nicht,
was einen erwartet.
Es kann sein, dass gerade
einer aus dem Fenster steigt.
Dann wird es hektisch.
Wenn einem wirklich unwohl ist,
kann man die Dienstwaffe ziehen
und in Bereitschaft gehen.
Dann ist man sicher bereit.
Gezückt hat er sie
in seiner 15-jährigen Dienstzeit
schon oft, abgedrückt noch nie.
Dort rechts habe ich
ein offenes Fenster gesehen.
Verstärkung ist eingetroffen.
Man sieht keine Einbruchsstelle,
nichts.
Dann gehen wir wieder.
Tschüss.
- (Frau) Ciao, vielen Dank.
Einen ruhigen Rest wünsche ich.
- Gleichfalls.
* Spannende Klänge *
Der dort ist der Mörder.
Ja.
- Der mit dem blöden Grinsen.
Wie viel hat das
mit der Realität zu tun?
Nicht viel.
Nein.
- Nicht wirklich viel.
Ein solcher Fall kann sich
monatelang hinziehen. - Genau.
Er ist nicht bereits
nach 1 1/2 Std. abgeschlossen.
Im Krimi schlafen sie halt nie.
Das ist der Vorteil.
3 Uhr morgens. Sie rücken erneut aus.
(Über Funk)
Zentrale: 1103, Grellingen, vor Ort.
Eine Betrunkene
beschimpft in einer Bar Gäste,
wirft Gläser
und verletzt dabei einen Mann.
Die Security stellt sie vor die Tür.
Sie weigert sich, zu gehen.
Ihr Wohnort.
- Ihr Wohnort.
* Die Frau lacht laut. *
Entschuldigung, aber wer sind Sie?
Herr Chappuis.
- Chappuis?
Genau. Und wer sind Sie?
Jetzt ist mir gerade
der Deckel runtergefallen.
Gott sei dank haben die Schuhe
noch einen Reissverschluss.
Sonst würde es mich glatt aus den
Socken, die ich nicht anhabe ...
Haben Sie einen Ausweis?
Das würde uns helfen.
15 Min. später.
Ich verlangte
schon lange Ihren Ausweis.
Das ist immer dieselbe Frage
und ich erhalte nie eine Antwort.
Wir wollen jetzt den Ausweis.
Moment, Herr Chappuis ...
- Bleiben Sie bitte stehen.
Nein, nein, ich greife Sie nicht an.
Nein, Sie müssen mir nicht zu nahe
kommen. Einfach etwas Distanz.
Stinke ich?
- Nein. Einfach nicht zu nahe.
Wo wohnen Sie?
In meinem Körper.
Das ist dieses Ding mit Haut.
Irgendwie Haut darum herum.
- Mmh.
Es sei angeblich das grösste Organ.
C wie ...
Sie hat keinen Ausweis,
verrät aber Name und Wohnort.
Dieses Dingsda ...
Meine Zahnbürste ist runtergefallen!
Was machen wir mit ihr?
Wie kommen Sie nach Hause?
Mit dem Velo.
Das denke ich nicht.
Das ist in Ihrem Zustand verboten.
Sollen wir Ihnen ein Taxi rufen?
* Sie schnaubt abfällig. *
* Er ahmt sie nach. *
- Das haben andere wohl nötiger.
Wir bleiben
nicht mehr lange hier mit Ihnen.
Entweder Sie organisieren etwas
oder wir rufen Ihnen ein Taxi.
Hier länger rumlungern
können Sie nicht. Das geht nicht.
Was heisst rumlungern?
Gibt es das auch auf Deutsch?
Nein, das ist ziemlich Deutsch.
Also, wir fahren Sie nach Hause.
Ist das okay? Ist das ein Deal?
Chappuis: für einmal Taxifahrer.
- Steigen Sie ein!
Und was tue ich jetzt
mit meinem Velo?
Das können Sie morgen holen.
Das bleibt besser hier. Damit
kommen Sie heute nicht nach Hause.
Kommen Sie, steigen Sie ein!
Ich will ja
nicht unfreundlich sein ...
Ja, ich auch nicht.
Ich auch nicht, aber ich
werde zunehmend unfreundlich,
wenn Sie jetzt nicht einsteigen.
- Warum?
Weil Sie nicht einsteigen.
Häh?
- Ja.
Ja ...
* Sie beginnt zu lachen. *
Entschuldigung,
ich lache Sie nicht aus, aber ...
Jetzt steigen Sie bitte ein!
Aber es gibt gewissermassen
eine Art von Situationskomik.
Wie lange soll das noch gehen, Rolf?
- Ich biete Ihnen jetzt etwas an.
Noch 5 Min.?
- Wie bitte?
Wir machen das hier
nicht mehr lange.
Es gibt zwei Opt...
- Wissen Sie was ...
Hören Sie mir jetzt zu!
Es gibt zwei Optionen.
Option A: Sie steigen jetzt ein
und wir fahren Sie nach Hause.
Dann ist das Ganze erledigt.
Option B:
Wir legen Ihnen Handschellen an
und bringen Sie
in die Ausnüchterung.
So ein Theater
will ich jetzt nicht mehr haben.
A oder B?
- Sie sind so streng ...
Nein, wir sollten für andere,
wichtige Dinge frei sein.
Wissen Sie was?
- Nicht für dieses Getue hier.
Ich mache Ihnen
jetzt ein Geschenksangebot,
und zwar von Herzen.
- Nein!
Moment! Wenn Sie mir jetzt
nicht zuhören können, nehmen Sie ...
Ich höre Ihnen schon
seit einer Viertelstunde zu.
Nein, Sie haben keine Ahnung.
Ihr Gehirn ist in dieser Hinsicht
falsch programmiert.
Okay, anscheinend.
- Radikal gemein.
So, jetzt steigen Sie bitte ein!
Ich werde jetzt ...
- Steigen Sie jetzt bitte ein!
Warum?
Ganz einfach, weil wir Ihnen
jetzt Handschellen anlegen.
Wie bitte?
Oh!
(Ironisch) Sie sind aber sehr nett.
Achtung, wenn die Brille
kaputt geht, bezahlen Sie sie.
Nach hinten, Rolf.
* Die Frau kreischt wütend. *
(Schreiend) Das tut weh!
* Sie kreischt. *
Hören Sie auf, so stark zu drücken!
- Ja, dann ...
Rein! Einsteigen.
Wissen Sie was? Das ist saugemein.
- Ich gehe auf die andere Seite.
Also, normal hinsetzen.
2,3 mm locker lassen.
Sonst schnüren Sie mir ...
Hey!
- Jetzt reicht's langsam!
Jetzt reicht's, ja.
- Ja, jetzt reicht's definitiv.
Jetzt reicht's.
So, jetzt ist Schluss.
- Weisst du was?
Kabelbinder.
- Ja, hole Kabelbinder.
Du stirbst, verdammt, du Sau!
- Du musst zwei nehmen.
Ich ficke dich im Fliegen,
ich ficke dich in den Ohrenspitzen.
Ja, ja.
Ihr seid so verdammte Drecksäue!
Habt ihr keine anderen Probleme?
- Anscheinend nicht.
Sie wollten es ja so. Sie wären
schon lange zu Hause im Bett.
Wie bitte?
- Sie wären schon lange zu Hause.
Woran hätte ich das merken sollen?
Oh Mann!
Das gibt's doch nicht, echt!
Sie verbringt die Nacht
in der Ausnüchterungszelle.
Nehmen einem Erlebnisse wie dieses
längerfristig
den Glauben an das Gute?
Bleiben solche Beleidigungen hängen?
- Das interessiert mich nicht.
Das nehme ich nicht persönlich.
Ich staune, was für ein flüssiges
Mundwerk gewisse Leute haben,
wenn sie getrunken haben.
Ich glaube, ich könnte nicht so
viele böse Worte aneinanderreihen.
Aber es gibt auch Momente,
in denen einem die Leute wirklich
Dankbarkeit entgegenbringen.
Das wiegt es wieder auf.
Yves Chappuis versucht,
jedem Fall gerecht zu werden.
Mal lässt er Nähe zu,
mal weiss er sich abzugrenzen.
Auf dem Weg zu einem
schwererziehbaren 17-Jährigen.
Er soll umplatziert werden -
von einer Gastfamilie in ein Heim.
Das letzte Mal,
dass Sie die Vielfalt erleben.
Jetzt noch dieser Jugendliche.
- Ja.
Wo ist er?
- Noch einen Stock höher.
Okay.
(Frau) Und es ist abgeschlossen.
- Und vielleicht noch etwas:
Er hat fast ein Jahr lang trainiert.
Es könnte sein, dass ...
Er ist recht kräftig.
Weiss er, dass wir kommen?
- Ja.
Okay. - Ich klopfte und rief,
aber er antwortete nicht.
Yannick und Nicolas,
könnt ihr auch ins Gebäude kommen?
Chappuis bietet Verstärkung auf.
Äh, das weiss ich nicht.
Sprechen wir ihn mal an.
Die Polizei ist hier.
Öffnest du die Tür?
(Flüsternd) Kommt er hier weg?
- Nein, es ist hoch.
* Klopfen *
Mach es uns einfacher!
Öffne die Tür!
Das ist für dich
und für uns einfacher.
Fehlanzeige, was?
Vom 17-Jährigen fehlt jede Spur.
Okay.
Warum war diese Tür verschlossen?
War das verklemmt?
Ah, sieh an!
Das ist ein Dings ...
Er hat das simuliert.
Er brachte einen Draht an
und zog von aussen.
Der hier ist es.
Der Jugendliche
wird zur Fahndung ausgeschrieben.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Chappuis' Alltag -
immer wieder überraschend.
Es gibt einem einen Einblick
in andere Lebensarten
und Problematiken,
die man selbst zum Glück nicht kennt
oder nicht hat.
Aber es ist sehr interessant,
die verschiedenen Geschichten
zu hören,
zu bearbeiten und dabei zu sein.
In gewissen Situationen gibt es
einem jedoch schon zu denken,
was in der Gesellschaft abgeht.
Yves Chappuis rückt aus.
Nicht immer ist es wie im Krimi.
Aber jede kleine Sache hat das
Potenzial, sich dazu zu entwickeln.